today I want to share with you one of
the only feasible methods that I know of
for Escaping The Rat Race part two step
number four the three R's risk
management rinse and repeat never ever
bet more than you can afford to lose
don't borrow money don't sell the house
don't go all in on a bet because you
could be wrong only bet what you can
afford to lose so that you can survive
to bet again which is the rinse and
repeat part step number five diversify
and chill out if you ever hit the
jackpot with an asymmetrical bat you
should have life-changing money on your
hands then you should focus your time on
figuring out how to preserve your wealth
as you'll be in a position where making
sure your money is well managed will
probably make you more money than your
old job would have I know all of this
sounds risky which is why again you
should speak with your financial advisor
before doing anything with your money
follow us for more helpful tips